so
next 30 minutes we'll discuss
envelopes lifecycle what it is and i
want to focus more on
questions that you would want to ask
when you start machine learning project
and
questions in each of these particular
stages in this life cycle less related
to the actual technical implementation
because it varies a lot and no sense to
discuss it
and also
yeah i will make some comparison between
envelopes and devops and in the end
just some
discussion and notes about team
uh it's like machine learning team roles
and responsibilities i found it quite
fascinating to discuss this topic these
days and tooling yeah but it will be
super brief
so
what is mlops
it works
cool
so
yes technical issues yeah so envelopes
is a set of the
processes that you would like to have in
place in order to move your um
models that you design in jupiter
notebook to something that can be
actually
yeah used by your customers and bring
the value to your organization there's
more complex uh definition here but yeah
in a nutshell
set of processes
and yeah also technologies and
capabilities and there's a bunch of
people involved
and two key things is that you want to
do it
rapidly which means you don't want to
start project and then after eight
months to have something in production
you maybe want to have something in
production within first month
and reliably which means yeah as soon as
you put your ex boost model and then the
actual data hits it and everything fails
and nothing is working you don't want
that you want to have it reliable
and
one more important part to say that i'm
not going to discuss data ops yeah for
those who
okay
it's a bit yeah
data ops is about the data so it's
completely different topic it's more on
um yeah if you're in a big organization
there's a separate team preparing your
data do all the quality checks putting
into the data warehouse or data lake
and envelopes team is not bothered with
that at all they are just customers they
just consuming that and best case
scenario
uh without data ops
yeah
if you don't have it or you never
thought about it yeah you can just keep
this talk and first focus on the data so
all other things doesn't make any sense
without it in place
but yeah data ops is about
yeah
data prepared data so
so back to envelopes so this wheel of
fortune or you know cycle of existence
call it whatever so you have several
processes around envelopes that needs to
be in place and the top one well top one
it's machine learning development we all
know what it is so it's you you see it
you create your training pipeline
um maybe do some tests if you're really
into that but usually it's just bunch of
steps in the jupyter notebook and then
it's called the pipeline
and we're all doing that for already a
lot of years then another thing
it's like
strange clicker
training apparently appears
standardization so this this thing is
that when you have your pipeline but
then you can take it and put it in some
system that can run it automatically so
for example to system that supports
continuous integration and continuous
deployment something that you can later
on run on some trigger or something this
is more like kind of a next step so you
take your pipeline which could be
whatever
um
i don't know air flow pipeline or
whatever and you put it like in the
system that can
deploy it on demand or on the trigger on
schedule so that's all about that um
continuous training
that's a bit of a glitch here
okay
so this one it's the set of processes
how you would like to run this
continuous training how you want to run
this pipeline that's operationalized
already so
um here you would like to think about
okay
should i check my data if something
wrong with the data that's coming to the
production part like okay should i
retrain it where should i retrain it
what kind of triggers i would like to
put so that's part is all about that and
yeah the simple thing is the code
changes so if your data scientist change
the pipeline or hyper parameters or
something you would like to run it all
and to have updated version
of the model registered in some model
registry
deployment again boring stuff packaging
testing and deploying it to some serving
environment you yeah we have several
like development environment it's always
nice to have development environment
like a full cycle where your data
scientists can also deploy it somewhere
and check that it works
prediction serving so it's more related
already to actual production environment
it's also separate process that you
would like to follow and then here also
stakeholders involved they would like to
see what's going on it's not only for
your internal team but also for someone
else outside
and the last thing is monitoring so
here bunch of things that you would like
to monitor business metrics software
metrics uh machine learning metrics
whatever
that's kind of the process
but still it's a wrong representation
because it's not cycle in real life you
see that there's a data in model
management that's the core part where
all your model artifacts are going all
the uh
all the registered models and also the
data that you're pre-processing it's all
there it's in this in the center
uh there's another view for the same
thing and this i think a bit better
because here you can see the outputs of
the each step
more in detail and it's also super clear
that
it's not a waterfall process
it's not even like highly
iterative process it's super iterative
process so you can basically go
at any moment in time you can return
back to the machine learning development
you can
which means you need to change something
in your
experimentation at any time you can
retrain your model at any time you would
like to redeploy it a lot of moving
pieces so
and
yeah
the outputs i already mentioned but
essentially yeah code configuration
after you did your experimentation then
pipeline uh from continuous training you
just register your model
um and serving yeah that's all
fascinating but these steps should be
there someone from the op side in your
team should do that that's the workflow
then
yeah
so
what i wanted to emphasize before we go
into the really details of uh
envelopes as a process
is that the first stage when you start
doing anything in machine learning it's
a scoping so there's a room like this
you have your solution architect you
have business stakeholder you have maybe
some development team discussing things
right so
and at this point in time you can kill
already 80 percent of the machine
learning projects and just do something
else you know just don't waste time on
it so that's really important and here
what kind of questions you need to ask
it's also important so i'm going to read
it but essentially
you may have in your organization
several projects that you would like to
work on right starting from
um
i don't know improving the customer
experience maybe working on the
databases maybe doing some internal uh
improvements and you all thinking about
ai right okay can i apply i there there
there so there should be some thinking
how to prioritize that i will link in
the references some material that you
can read about that but it's a separate
thing that you really need to put effort
which project to pick that will improve
your
company essentially
another thing is what kind of metrics
for success uh
you define so i don't know
different people interested in different
things right devops people they may be
interested like in general ops people
they're interested in latency in
throughput whatever how to deploy
kubernetes cluster yaml files and all
the stuff and
business people they don't speak
language of technical people right like
machine learning engineers saying like
my rmc is good and then uh business
person is like so what okay fine
so you need to ask those questions and
also in terms of planning like what kind
of people you have i saw projects
starting that where you need to spin up
i don't know kubernetes cluster build
all
all that thing from scratch and then
there's only one data scientist that
barely knows uh
anything else except jupiter notebook so
yeah put some proper people on the
project timeline as well is important
so um
yeah what's important
more than that it's that to separate
problem identification from solution you
know that every month we have a new
transformer architecture coming right
and then like ah we can apply to
everything right these days computer
vision uh natural language processing
everything so and people like okay aii
yeah just discuss what you're actually
trying to solve if you can avoid machine
learning do it you will save money time
for everyone um
yeah probably i'm not supposed to talk
like that right
and then another thing is that that
everyone is happy about the success
metrics so you build that bridge between
your machine learning engineers and the
business stakeholders
next one
yeah that's like in the end when you're
done you ask again that question like
um
let's see
data
that's fascinating part so
um
that's the questions that you need to
ask so you need to understand i will say
obvious things now you need to
understand what's your input data and
what actually you're predicting that's
like
the best of it and then more tricky is
that in which situation you are whether
you have small data set or big data set
why it's important it affects other
things right like it affects your
labeling strategy if you have small data
set and it's difficult to obtain maybe
you need to involve a lot of subject
matter experts or it's just pricey you
cannot outsource it or whatever you need
to make sure that quality of your labels
is great so it's like completely
different when you have
huge data like labeled yeah reliably but
you can work with that right you can
mangle it you can apply data
augmentation techniques to that so you
need to identify that from the beginning
then structured unstructured data also
important also in terms of labeling it's
way easier to label
unstructured data images yeah even
machine learning engineer can label that
with some small instructions if you have
uh structured data which is like yeah
csv table with 1000 features and some
like zero one in the end like yeah good
luck with that it's uh almost impossible
um
what else yeah you need to be aware of
the data lineage so the steps usually
machine learning is not the first thing
that company is implementing you may
have already a lot of things in your
pipeline and you need to plug it in so
you need to know where exactly you're
plugging it in because when it breaks
you you will know like okay that's maybe
it's not your fault it's fault of
downstream or upstream systems so that's
uh also important question
um
[Music]
yeah
whether your data cent the data set is
balanced or not i found it is also
really important because this imbalanced
data sets they affect performance a lot
and you need to know if it's balanced
how to tackle it there's multiple
methods for that but yeah just be aware
how to handle data errors
this one important because usually you
have like a snippet of the data set csv
file you open jupyter notebook you work
there but you kind of
yeah rarely ask a question what will
happen if the schema will change of this
data set what will happen if someone
will add new category there how i will
track it and all these issues they
usually discovered when your model
deployed in production when it's too
late so and
it's better if you start asking these
questions in advance
then how fast your data is changing also
for example customer data is not
changing that often
but
if you work with manufacturing plant or
whatever they may add things every week
so this will also affect decisions later
on
um
yeah another thing how to measure and
act on data drift
so data drift is the situation when you
train your model on one thing but then
production data distributed differently
and then your model is not predicting it
well which means
yeah
it's not a good thing so you need to
have some ideas and methods how you will
mitigate the drift already on this stage
um
yeah i think one advice it's important
to
incorporate as much as possible metadata
for your data it will help you a lot and
also will help you uh explaining to your
customers in the end like okay
why your model is not working sometimes
i've been in a situation when people are
saying like your model isn't working
everything is broken completely i look
in the metadata everything works
perfectly and i see that um actually the
equipment is broken so we had the camera
installed and camera was just
closed so it was like black image coming
into the system and they was like it's
not predicting anything like yeah
because you're not sending any data and
then in metadata you can see some
characteristics of your input data for
example as well
collect your data fast if possible so
this is to the moment of like okay
uh don't wait three months before
someone will give you that csv file and
then you start doing that if just don't
start the project just leave them be and
when they are done where they're ready
with the data you can actually start
doing something and iterating the model
development cycle faster
so this is about datum
okay modeling let me just put
everything here on the slide
just keep clicking
okay
so modeling um obvious things for some
people i guess but um yeah in the first
week
when you already know that the project
will fly you have some ideas that yeah
just start with literature search check
blogs etc i always suggest look at open
source because it's already done you
just take it you run it you see first
results
uh overfit a small training data set
first i think that's a common
recommendation when you train neural
networks overfeed one batch to see that
your
neural network can actually learn small
sample or feed on that because if it
can't there's some problems in algorithm
technical problems that you need to
solve
after some time yeah you may start
thinking about explainability and
this something that yeah some people
saying that you need to think about that
in production i think you need to think
about it when you're in jupiter notebook
so
apply something like yeah explain
abilities it's equal to sharp these days
right like shop is everywhere uh for
neural networks that on computer vision
in computer vision world you can apply
other things gradient-based methods
ablations whatever but have it in your
training pipeline
create a strategy to monitor concept
drift so concept drift is another beast
it's basically when your
mapping is changing over time so i think
yeah
you have same house uh size and it's
price changing due to inflation so you
need to this is to the mo to the point
when you have to retrain your model so
there should be a trigger as soon as you
detect concept drift the model is
retrained on the new data
and module is update so but also take
that into account
what else
challenges do well on the training data
set easy we can all over feed on the
training data set then do well on the
validation and test set is also
uh yeah well a bit more tricky but we
also can do that we also can do
something with that and it will work
well do well on the business metrics
that's hard
so good luck
another thing is um
yeah so don't be obsessed without the
algorithms these days so uh
the typical like trap that okay i tried
random forest i tried gradient boosted
trees neural network transformer
transformer is not really working let's
try another transformer
better invest in the data there's a lot
of discussions especially this year
about data centric ai that you focus on
your data first
and then when you focus on your model
later on especially if you're not doing
a research because yeah if you're doing
research maybe you're interested in
in the models and developing the models
but in in industry it's barely the case
uh take deployment constraints into
account after you establish a baseline
this is about the freedom for your data
scientists so instead of saying like the
algorithm should run on this lambda
function within 20 milliseconds just
give them to do whatever they want and
optimization comes afterwards so it's
always possible to tweak this deployment
requirements later on
um
what else yeah and machine learning is
an iterative process so it's mostly for
i guess
managers if there's any managers because
still a lot of people believe that you
do it once and then you take the pickle
file you deploy it on the server and it
works forever that's not the case
okay deployment let's put a lot of
boring words here yeah
so on deployment
uh you need to think about whether it's
a real time or batch completely
different stories require completely
well different level of skills in your
team batch workloads way easier than
real time
uh you need to decide whether you deploy
in the cloud or on the earth or on the
edge or in your on-prem
that could be yeah also something that
you need to
realize before you start computer
resources whether you need gpu cpu gpu
memory whatever latency throughput some
logging some security and privacy part
deployment patterns so for about
deployment patterns i think for ai
this kind of diagram is relevant so you
first start when someone is doing the
process manually so it's like person
looking in the excel spreadsheet
let's assume and then you want to
automate something so you run some chat
bot or some kind of process in the
shadow mode that's not really
affecting a user anyhow it's just
running and then you check how it's
performing and then as soon as it's
performing well you're moving it from
shadow mode to ai assistant so for the
person that in excel like your chatbot
is saying like hey maybe you want to ask
me and
delete excel from your laptop
and then there's a partial automation
and full automation but it's more like
when you substitute the particular
process with the ai
for one use case so for example you put
quality control station in the factory
on one line and it's fully working and
you and your operator's not bothered and
then you substitute the whole station
uh whole factory checking process with
ai so
i think most common ways
were to stop its assistance and
partial automation full automation is
still yeah tricky
and deployment is also an iterative
process because modeling is an iterative
process so
let's see
monitoring and observability
okay
so this one
uh if you
took into account everything that i said
before
concept drift data drift software
metrics business metrics beforehand this
step is super easy because essentially
monitoring is just yeah it's just
dashboard right like
if you're an open source you use grafana
if you're in azure you use log analytics
if you're in aws you use i know what's
that quick site so it doesn't matter
literally if you know what to put in the
dashboard and to whom to show it that's
most important part so you want to show
it to your data scientist you want to
show it to your business stakeholders
and to your infrastructure devops
engineers i guess
so and the things that should be there
yeah they're on the slide software
metrics uh
drift
data quality data some performance
analysis for machine learning models so
machine learning metrics
and
in case like yeah explainability is also
there so that for example
when something is happening in
production like one feature start
deviating in terms of
in distribution from the one that you
have in the test you can see it in the
dashboard plus
you can see for example from the shop
you can see how much that change in the
data drift influencing the prediction of
that model so you need to put some
thinking in how to build that dashboard
but yeah the all things are there
yeah you can bring brainstorm with your
team to think like okay maybe there's
some special metrics that i want to put
there or yeah some particular
requirements whatever
and
more on observability
uh part because okay dashboard is there
it's showing that everything is ruined
in production and all metrics are off
what to do with that because no one is
looking at the dashboards right you need
uh alerting functionality so you need to
notify relevant stakeholders data
scientists engineers about things that
going on within your system and yeah i
think all the systems that i mentioned
they support that
okay monitor software yeah that's i
already mentioned so you need to monitor
literally everything
machine learning ops and devops so
how much time i still have
yeah
so this one is really interesting
because people like now we're in the
world of everything ops right you just
take opsworld and you attach it to
anything and then it's a new thing so
the difference is in the data so
if you look for example in traditional
application it's purely logical every
blocks everything is explainable you can
open any component and yeah look into
that and it's done right
in machine learning a world everything
is empirical so everything depends what
your data science is doing in that
jupyter notebooks in the end right you
can build all the clusters all the
infrastructure around that but the most
important part is that model in the end
how it performs is it really working or
not and it's a bit of the magic and we
know all right right it's like you're
experimenting a lot you're trying
different approaches and then something
is working so that's the difference
that's why you cannot just take devops
as a as a methodology and apply to
machine learning world because you need
to take into account like this kind of
randomness and the empirical way of
working for machine learning workloads
so
that one
this picture is explaining basically the
layers that you would want to have and
some of these things
yeah they are coming from the devops
world right you need foundational
infrastructure you need your data you
need some compute you need orchestration
versioning comes also from devops for
your data for your model
what else yeah for your code obviously
and
yeah software architecture as well
those things that i mentioned it's the
things that data scientists don't care
at all they only care about model
development feature engineering and
maybe model operations like slightly
so that's where these two worlds are
attached to each other so
and
what's important on that is that
uh let's say you have a
data scientist that's uh
yeah i think it's on the next one
oh no
okay i'll go later to that
so
this one is another thing this is about
uh roles and responsibilities in machine
learning team
so i was looking uh
when i was making the slide i was
thinking like okay we have devops
model ops devsec ops i don't know and i
thought like okay i'll call it xops and
then i google this and this thing is
exist actually we have xops now as well
so someone is writing blocks about that
like whether it's a hype or whatever
okay fine
so what about this unicorn yeah people
some people trying to hire those guys
those guys in the team right they want a
person to understand yaml to write
manifest files for kubernetes then open
jupyter notebook take latest transformer
model train it on the data set then also
deploy it then also attend the stand-up
because of course you need to manage
your team right but actually it's a
small team so it's like one person so
you probably can skip stand-ups but you
still need agile
that's like for sure so
don't do that don't
don't hire
don't look for such people because i saw
a lot of vacancies doing that you will
not find such person it's a mythology so
in reality um we have a gradient so a
lot of people they're all different so
you have
and there's a two access to that right
like you have machine learning knowledge
and you have software engineering
knowledge and depends in which
organization you are you can cherry pick
who you want well actually not you
cannot cherry pick because machine
learning engineers are super difficult
to hire because they are kind of they on
the boards both worlds
uh but i just pick one example so
yeah so this example is that when we
have some product and we would like to
embed the machine learning functionality
into that product
so i think it's quite obvious that
software skills in this case are
prioritized over the research skills and
then yeah as i mentioned machine
learning team is not managing the data
so you have a separate team doing all
the data ops and everything
and then machine learning engineers own
the models that they deploy so in this
situation it's quite clear that you
probably need people like machine
learning engineers right you need the
devops to kind of operate around the
model
[Music]
i would say that the best recommendation
always is that if you don't have anyone
in the team start with data engineer
because someone have to move the data
around even though if you have a
separate data ops team someone have to
communicate with them bring it in your
system do something with that so having
a data engineer in the team it's really
really important
but yeah others like data scientists
umbrella term always clarify what people
mean about data scientists as i said it
varies from like writing
macros
expressions in excel to kubernetes
clusters so
don't like this term so let's
be careful with that
and
yeah let me see
and there's another story that i wanted
to
to briefly throw on you is that some
people saying that data scientists
should be end to end so it's back to
that unicorn discussion but
uh let's just stop for a second and stop
shaming those people but think about the
benefits so imagine that you are one
data scientist on the project
the advantage is that you have ownership
of everything right you know where the
data coming from what's going on with
the data how is it deployed you know all
the metrics you own the process
which means
you also iterate fast and you learn fast
in such environment and also it's
reduced communication and collaboration
overhead because
when
you have
data data engineer that builds some
table in sql and then throw it to data
scientist data scientist looks in that
and then okay i will do it in r and it's
doing something in r and then move it to
machine learning engineer and machine
learning engineering you're like okay r
no way to
write everything in go for example and
then
you like uh okay that's that's a lot of
traction in the process but as i
mentioned the problem is these guys
right like you're thinking okay i'm data
scientist now i need to know low level
infrastructure pipelines all these
things and like no right what to do so
i find a really good
opportunity in that discussion and it's
on the tooling side
and if it appears yeah this is good
example who knows meta flow
okay some people i will just uh follow
up on that so basically
the problem is tooling so if data
scientist has a tool
that allow him to deploy things
not writing yaml files or not deploying
kubernetes clusters but just to deploy
then
in the language that data scientist
knows which is python well sorry are
people
uh but
this is basically an example how things
can work in future so meta flow for
those who in aws like if you are vendor
locked on aws you can try that because
they support a lot of workloads in
aws but essentially this is kind of a
pipeline right so you have a class
it's inherited from some flow spec but
what i want to emphasize there's a laser
here right that's not visible okay so
there's the decorators there light you
see
step decorator you see batch decorator
you see on the decorator so
these things allows you to
declare a particular step in a way that
it will then later on be
executed in the cloud environment from
the data scientist point of view you
just need to configure one file it also
can be configured by your engineer for
you but you just need to specify okay i
need four gpus or 100 maybe you're maybe
in your language models then you need a
lot and how much memory you need and the
libraries also and in that sense you
have one file
and it will enable data scientists to
work and to end
essentially right so you do need to ask
someone
uh
to provide a particular environment for
you because we have the serverless
compute well serverless right you ask
for example this batch decorator will
call aws batch service so what that
service is doing is just taking your
code running it in the docker container
and put the results for example to s3
perfect right everything can be
configured
okay
highly recommend that especially in aws
they also support kubernetes integration
so for ops people there it's like really
cool thing to give to your data
scientists and make them more autonomous
yeah questions if you have any and this
is the references that i highly
recommend to uh to take a look on
they will answer a lot of things that
you are wondering about envelopes as a
process
[Applause]
thanks vladimir
questions
uh thanks for the
amazing presentation i do have a
question because i missed a
important part actually during the
entire ml ml ops cycle i think a b
testing because uh before you're really
actually pushing anything to production
you have to kind of like uh doing like a
let's say the your hypothesis and test
actually
based on the or let's say new features
actually enabled compared to that that's
a non-hypothetical you have
so
yeah i'm just wondering like uh how do
you actually view that as part of them
alps actually this actually happens at
the
uh that deployment stage actually you're
mentioning already or it's like
happening
after that yeah that's a really good
question that's like one particular
example how you can start with
deployment right so a b testing is
definitely in the deployment stage so i
just i'm yeah i cannot go in all
possible ways how you want to deploy but
yeah a b testing is there indeed on the
deployment stage so
because
versioning you do everywhere starting
from your experiments on the machine
learning experimentation part so your
data scientists they already have to
version something
on that site
yeah i'm sorry
so uh
because you are talking about ops right
so
there's like
there's like a
flow
deliver you're actually mentioning from
the uh data ops to ml ops to the devops
right
um
if you do the ap testing at end of the
ops how you actually just seamlessly
continuously deliver to the people
actually responsible for the let's say
uh downstream part
well at least what i'm trying to do also
at work is that
data scientists should own the process
right so you can deploy in your
development environment for example for
development endpoints your model already
and you can already expose it to some
customers right and see how it's working
and then at some point in time when your
model is showing good results you can
promote it to production but there's no
walls between
i mean we used to work like that right
you do something and then you throw over
the wall like those guys that department
will do that no
they see everything
and the go but it doesn't mean that you
shouldn't have uh uh infrastructure
people on your project you should they
will help data scientists to see this
flow end to end
so it's a bit different approach instead
of like separating walls and then
waiting several months one wine team
will
put it in the backlog you know like okay
we do that in three months we will
create a skill table for you you can
wait
so yeah but yeah that's
you